we also have a touch of good news on
covid new covet cases and deaths are
finally going down nationwide after a
devastating spike in january
and yet conditions in many hospitals are
still harrowing including for medical
workers
who are on the front lines of the
suffering our lead national
correspondent david begno
is at a california hospital this morning
where health care workers
are also working on themselves it
includes the mental health of the
doctors and nurses providing care david
good morning to you
good morning to you tony look the stress
and the grief that these front-line
workers are going through is really
immeasurable a lot of them
are actually seeking out counseling as
they're on duty
so in fact here in riverside where
you've got the military working right
alongside civilian staff
they have counselors actually walking
the halls of the icu the covet unit
looking out not only for families but
also for the nurses
as they are in the middle of their job
joe hargrave has been at riverside
university health system for more than
three weeks now
this army nurse is on his third covet
deployment
inside the united states on this day
two of the five patients he was caring
for took a very sudden
turn for the worse how was today tell me
uh
today was a day you just see them
come in they're alert they're oriented
they're talking to you
and then just to see them decline in
such a rapid rate
that was hard for me because every time
you go into the room you just kind of
have to be like okay
you know focus on me don't worry about
the monitor
you're doing well you're doing good
hargrave is haunted by what the virus is
doing not just to the patients
but to the families too their only news
about their loved one often comes over
the phone
and in many cases it's hargrave that's
connecting them
and when that person is nearing the end
only two family members
can come in and say goodbye today a wife
had
three children and it's like who do you
choose to come with you
to say goodbye to your father you know
if it was if
it was my father and my mom
had to make the decision about who would
go with her to say goodbye
he i just can't imagine that this virus
is taking an immense toll
on all of the healthcare workers like
hargrave according to psychiatrist
matthew chang
this is not a plane crash or hurricane
or
shooting the trauma it's not just an
acute one time trauma
was over and over again and that
requires a different type of response
so to help them process this trauma the
hospital has peer support specialists
who spend time with critical care staff
in meetings
and on the floor of the icu i'm always
grateful for it
[Music]
according to critical care director
nurse tammy lowe
even though the medical staff may have
gotten better at treating covet
dealing with it is still tough i know
that there are
staff members that have nightmares of
stacking bodies
nightmares of so many patients that they
can't
keep up with the tasks we're in there
hearing their stories and trying to
offer them
any support that we can
the peer support specialists are on the
halls of that icu 24 hours a day
just in case you know speaking of
captain hargrave who you saw at the top
of our report gail he talked about his
first day here where
a man died in the icu and they said okay
we got to clean it up get the room ready
because there's somebody in the
emergency department
waiting to come up and it turns out the
person waiting to come up was the wife
of the man who had just died and
hargrave said i told them we can't put
her in the same room as her husband we
have to find
a different room the grief gail the
grief that they feel
is hard it's hard to really detail
yeah now that we've heard it i know he
can't forget it now that we've heard it
we can't forget it either david i often
wonder
you know who is helping the people that
need the help i thought dr chang said it
very well when he said the grief goes
over and over and over again this is
very tough to hear and see
endless endless all right david begna we
thank you